patient patient point guard
uh waiting for kendrick to finish
because he is joining us and he is back
he is a two-time nba champion 14th ally
in big game james on the all-time
assist list
and how nice is it rajon rondo to be one
of the youngest guys on the team now
whoo that's amazing i went from the
oldest guy
four months ago to
arguably like i said middle of the pack
so i'm feeling good i'm feeling youthful
now and uh ready to go i think you know
this um because coming over from the
celtics it was a lot of talk about oh my
gosh rondo's coming over and all of a
sudden the championship the game winner
against boston everyone loves rondo and
then you leave we missed you we missed
you i hope you missed us but what was
the biggest reason for coming back
just winning the championship you know
the organization uh frank reached out
you know rob braun curt i mean the
entire family reached out and said i
thought they thought this would be a
good fit for me and likewise i don't
think i was going anywhere else you know
i knew i was traded to memphis but at
the same time
i just moved my family out here to la my
kids are here with me this year and i
was looking forward to that so it's just
been a blessing come full circle to come
back to the latest organization and
compete for a championship again
you know rondo you've you've heard just
about every question man over over the
media day so i don't really have any
questions but i always say
if if the entire
coaching staff got kicked out of the
game
rondo was still you do stand up there
we'd be okay we'd be okay i always say
that so i don't have i don't have any
questions in particular just give me
your spill on on where you are and the
season and whatever you want to convey
to the fans and everybody else i don't
have anything in particular man just go
ahead and do your thing i kind of know
it i want to know what your starting
five might be
just do your thing i appreciate the
compliments that's true i really do
believe that
yeah if that happened i mean i would
definitely be prepared and ready to go
uh it'd be a special moment but
obviously that's not going to happen but
uh
it's such a great talented team we have
and uh no matter who was coaching uh if
everybody kicked out it could be me
brian uh it could be austin reeves you
know it's just a matter of us guys
willing to sacrifice and play for one
another
and finding the open man is pretty
simple basketball
large in part that compliment rajon
comes because you're one of the most
intelligent players our game has ever
seen
um what when you look at the roster
right now as it's constructed what has
you excited um in terms of the way in
which you'll lead inside that locker
room
just our depth you know i think you know
no one has to burn out minutes um no one
has to try to you know pace himself
throughout the season i think we're all
have we're a very talented team and
in so many positions you know guys are
gonna change we can switch positions
guys can step up guys can take nights
off and and still compete at a high
level and expectations are to win every
night
is it kind of crazy um rondo to think
that that championship in the bubbles
less than a year ago or does it seem
like
a lifetime ago it seemed like it's three
yeah three four years ago
yeah seem
like i've been gone for so long but no
it it definitely feels a long time ago
and that's why uh coming back here this
year in particular is big big for me and
understand that we definitely want to
parade here in los angeles and you were
such a big part of that rotation as that
other playmaker is that the same role
you kind of see yourself as that guy
that can create uh uh you know give give
lebron a chance to not have that ball in
his hands and rust the entire time
um we have so many talented guys that
can make plays
you know i do pride myself on that's
what i do best as a play make but
whatever role this organization this
team asks of me whatever frank wants me
to do
that's the role i'm willing to step up
and do whether it's play 40 minutes a
night whether it's sit 40 games in a row
and coach you know i'm willing to do
what it takes and
i have one common goal year 16 no ego
here and i'm willing to do what it takes
uh to win a championship here as a laker
one one more time
rajon as you know it takes a team to
get back to the top but you were also a
part of a big three in boston
and now with the one that you guys have
constructed here in your mind what's the
key to success when it comes and starts
with that
it starts with the big three starts with
them sacrificing
allowing each other to blossom each game
is going to vary there's no
you know one go-to guy because all three
of them are are the best of what they do
so being with him for those guys starts
with them within the sacrifice and
everyone else
being ready to step up when they're row
when their name is called where their
number's called and make plays for each
other
rondo i remember when lonzo ball was in
new orleans he mentioned your name as a
vet that helped him
tht unsolicited said it on the air when
you look at these young guys
around you now the few that they have uh
how much pride do you take in in in that
part of the game and helping those young
guys
a lot of pride you know i think it's
it's only right for me to give back you
know i had great vets when i was a young
guy
20 21 years old i had you know kevin
garnett ray island paul pierce who was
my mentors and they came in every day
and showed what it took and and that's
for me to force like to give it back
you're 16.
any young guy they've always known that
i'm willing to to help in any way
possible whether it's watch film whether
it's stay and rebound for those guys is
whatever it takes as an older player on
the team to get those guys comfortable
and make them more accountable for for
night and night out play on our games
that's what i'm willing to do
rajon it's well documented the
relationship the respect between you and
anthony davis going back to new orleans
then obviously competing together for
that championship in 2020
what have you seen from him lately that
has you excited heading into this
season haven't seen anything uh
everyone's talking about how big he is
i actually made that he's right here
[Laughter]
i think he's been doing maybe like 18
push-ups a night or something like that
a little bigger but
other than that you know he's still
dominant a.d i look forward to you know
helping him any way possible
and getting another championship so
everyone's talking about how big he is
but
he's just saving me his nickname
speaking of rondo and a.d oh denver
series i know rondo goes to the coach
and says coach you sure you want me to
take it out you want me to take
it was crazy because i think i had about
four or five turnovers that game so you
know we had no time outside how he had
four turnovers i've been on the sideline
ice so i'm like
let's do it frank and he believed in me
and uh
the great ones do they always remember
their flaws and yeah he's talking about
it who cares about the five turnovers
even one of the coaches on the floor
yeah still coaches big games dream is
still alive of all the coaches getting
kicked out of the game he has set a time
rondo comes in and he still wants to
skip a beat all right we can't finish
yet we can't practice it i'm ready hold
on we got one i wouldn't doubt that um
we haven't talked yet to anyone rajan
about vegas the mini camp camp but we
heard that there is a nickname for the
young guy
or the rook i don't know
besides rook there's another nickname
man you're trying to get through that
love to you
i mean i don't
i can't give you that um he's just rook
to me you know both of them so
he can't give you that information
albeit you tried everyone else gave the
information but i tried i did
i did
i did
can you give it to us
hillbilly kobe
that's his name hillbilly kobe
travis called him light skin already so
i don't know
oh i love it man
you're the best rondo thank you for
coming back man we appreciate it
glad to be back appreciate you guys i'll
see you guys soon thanks so much all
right oh that was great how about this
active career assist leaders look at
this list